they got more missiles than any country
in the world they're just they it's like
as Stalin said quantity has a quality of
its own they can hit the palace in
Taiwan in seven minutes from the
mainland and you know what they you know
what they call aircraft carriers
American aircraft carriers in China
communist China targets right it's just
it's like a stupid wave it's a stupid
way to conduct Warfare with communist
China you don't put big aircraft
carriers in this Taiwan Straits and not
expect those things not to get shot down
I mean we should be putting all our
money into uh sea mines ringed around
Taiwan if we if we want to take that
democracy seriously and and and
submarines